I've studied and traded the futures
markets for years, and here's what I've
learned. Every futures market has its
own personality. In this video, I'm not
just going to break down the basics of
chart analysis, but the unique moves and
quirks of each futures market. So, by
the end of this video, you can have a
clear understanding of how to analyze
these futures markets and charts based
on what the candlesticks are doing. And
even if you already know some of that
basics, understanding how these futures
markets actually trade and differ from
each other in practice will completely
change how you actually trade and your
performance when it comes to trading.
And so when it comes to trading, a lot
of times you start out thinking that I
need, you know, 10 different indicators
on my chart and all these different
things that make it easy to, you know,
know what to do because it seems like an
indicator can just tell you what to do.
But at the end of the day, if you learn
to just do some of these basic chart
analysis things, you will drastically
improve your trading. And one of those
is just learning to look at the major
swing highs and swing lows of a market.
It will drastically improve your
understanding of the direction of the
overall trend. And when it comes to
actually entering in trades, the biggest
factor I always take into consideration,
no matter how good the more smaller
patterns look, is the overall big
picture of what the market is doing
because that is going to rule your trade
no matter what. It doesn't matter how
good a support level looks or a trend
line looks. If it's coming to a major
area where and your big picture analysis
of a trend is that it's overextended and
it needs to slow down, well, if you, you
know, jump in short right here and you
weren't looking at just that big
picture, you're going to be losing a lot
more trades than you want. And so, the
basics of, you know, downtrends and
uptrends are made by the market making
lower lows and lower highs or just the
swings are getting lower and lower. An
uptrend is just a flip where it's making
higher highs and higher lows. And this
really helps you just this basic
structure helps you stay on the right
side of the market of saying, "Okay,
well overall this thing is mainly making
lower lows and lower highs. There can be
some times where okay, it gets a little
back and forth here where it has a uh
you know right here it had actually more
of a quick uptrend before it continued
its downtrend. So that could have just
been a pullback in the major downtrend
that was taking place. And this can also
happen because what's happening is
you're at a transition period where you
are going from a downtrend where it's
making consistent lower lows and lower
highs and then all of a sudden it starts
making a higher low and then a higher
high and it shifts to an uptrend. So,
you're going to have these areas, and
these are really key to start to learn
is have areas where it starts to shift,
and you want to be aware of that because
that's when the trend is starting to
change. If you're either in a trade
betting that it's going to go down,
well, that's usually a signal to get
out. Or if you're looking for the market
to reverse to the upside, well, you can
take that into account for going long
and taking a reversal trade and trying
to buy the bottom of the swing. And so
super helpful thing with identifying a
lot of the swings in the market. And
this is just going to take you time to
understand is going through and you can
use things like a trend line. And so how
I like to draw trend lines is if I just
use a quick drawing to kind of show you
before we look at the charts cuz no
chart really looks like this. But a lot
of the time, what you want to do is you
want to essentially just match the
highs. The idea with the trend line is
you're matching it to all the main swing
highs that you're seeing. And then on
the flip side, you can also make what's
called a channel where essentially it's
both where the market doesn't do this a
lot of the time, but it can sometimes
make a channel where on the upside where
the pullbacks they will respect a
downtrend. And then on the the swing low
side is they'll also basically be be
respecting a downwards trending support
line. And this is a downwards trending
resistance line. And so what those do is
those essentially make a channel and
they make it really easy to identify
what the market is doing. Now because
the market is always changing now a
clear kind of one is on actually on a
bigger time frame right now. This is the
NASDAQ futures. So how you want to draw
a trend line and start one is you'll see
here we're looking at the big swings
here and then it makes a high here and
then it starts to just trend lower. Now
you're not going to know these right
away. It takes some time and you know it
usually takes at least two swings to be
able to draw that trend line before
knowing it could bounce off of it a
third time. And so I like to at least
wait for two swings to draw it off of.
And so here there's this big swing up
here and this swing right here. And so
for me I would take a drawing tool and
start it at the swing high here and then
draw it touching this next one. And then
so here you can see the market came up
here and it didn't quite touch this if
if you put it to exactly the highs. But
so that's the big thing about any tool
or drawing tool you use in the market
with support or resistance trend lines
anything you use take it with a grain of
salt. You can have some flexibility in
it. It's not going to be okay well it
didn't touch my line exactly so I'm not
going to it it didn't count right. Think
of it more of like a zone. This is a big
thing I do and we'll talk about it in a
minute with my support or resistance
levels is I don't think of it like one
line. I think of it as an area where
okay, well the market will come up here
somewhere and reverse lower versus this,
you know, it it's a big line. I don't
wait for it to come exactly up here. So
if it's coming up here, I'm thinking,
okay, well, it's close and you know, if
if a trade set up off that, then I would
take a trade off of it. And so once it
finishes, well then I'm going to adjust
based on that because I consider this to
be a pretty clear touch and a reversal.
And so going forwards again, I would
look at that and say, okay, well extend
this out and see what happens. And this
is where trend lines and everything
become very subjective is you can match
this either with the highs or you can
also drag it down here and say, well, it
kind of there's all these bodies here.
Well, if you do that, you can see that
this got a lot closer here and made a
lot more sense. And so that's where
drawing tools can be a little tricky or
drawing trend lines can be a little
tricky is it can be very subjective
because you can see here well once we
got down here and down here is what
pretty much was touching these ones as
well. And so that's kind of how trend
lines work. And so that's why we're
drawing them. My kind of rule of thumb
is take it with a grain of salt. It
doesn't count as a break of the trend
line if it, you know, breaks by one
candlestick and goes back in or it has a
wick that breaks above. A clean break of
a trend line is where the candlesticks
clearly break out here like this. And so
kind of on the flip side, what that can
look like, just to find you a quick
example here, here's another just moving
back in the chart a little bit. Here's
kind of a trend line right here I would
consider. And you can see here it's
clearly broken that. And so at that
point I would say, hey, I think that
this trend is over. The potential there
means that it's it could either go
sideways or it could reverse to the
upside. And so from that point, you
know, you would use whatever other
factors you're using an analysis like
support zone here. I already have drawn
on the chart or just looking at the big
picture. Where are the big swings uh in
the market and kind of what's been going
on. So at that point, it looks like
okay, yeah, it's kind of bouncing and I
would look for, you know, kind of a move
off of that. And so when it comes to
practically using trend lines, they're
going to be broken pretty quickly a lot
of the time. And a good example was
actually this morning in gold where on a
actually a one minute chart here is it
had a really nice bottom here and a
trend line up. And so the market just
followed this for a while until it
eventually broke. And so you can have
multiple types of trend lines where
they're really sharp here and and just
kind of very fastpaced or like that
bigger picture downtrend one they were
looking at. And even gold actually has
one going on right now too is zooming
out to more of a bigger picture
15-minute chart. As you can see here,
it's got this, you know, it made a a
larger swing high right here, kind of a
double top, and then it's had two clear
swings here, and then the third one, I
think, pretty clearly bounced off of
that. And so, another example here is on
the flip side, you can see on the bottom
end, I've drawn a swing off of these
two. And then there's this third one
right here. And so, it looks like it's
clearly starting to bounce there, find
some support. And so that's how you can
start to use these as clearly predicting
where the market could slow down in
reverse. Now one last one is it I call
it a spike in channel or a spike in
trend where uh a lot of times in a
beginning of a move the market right
here you can see it does a quick spike
where it just moves very rapidly in one
direction and then it starts to slow
down into more of a methodical trend.
Now, this one's still pretty tight here,
but you can have it essentially on the
flip side, too, on a on an uptrend where
it goes up and then it starts to go into
more of a healthier trend. The market
has a lot of different types of trends
where, you know, they're unhealthy moves
like this where they're likely to have a
pullback or consolidation at some point
or more healthier moves where, you know,
like this, if we zoom out, where, you
know, it it's slowly moving back and
forth. And that's more of a rangebound
move. And when it comes to trading
futures, I've always found it be to be
very important to stick to when there's
more volatility in the market because
trading in, you know, a choppy market.
This is the NASDAQ yesterday on a
5-minute chart. This is the whole day of
trading basically. And this is the first
kind of two hours. And you can see it
just sat here and did nothing. And so
that's times where you kind of want to
stay out and not watch the market too
much and save your money for a day where
you have more volatility like this where
there's more moves that are more
tradable. And so this is where
timeframes are really important to pay
attention to. You can trade whatever
time frame you want, but when it comes
to futures, I highly recommend sticking
to entering your trades on either a one
minute chart or a five-minute chart. And
then bigger picture, you can look at I
like to look at a 15inut chart or a 30
minute chart for kind of understanding
the broader picture of what the market's
doing, drawing these kind of bigger
swing moves. And that really helps you
understand the big picture of what's
going on because you can easily see,
okay, based on just the swings of the
market right here in gold that it's
pretty back and forth right now. It's
kind of in this downwards tightening
wedge that's going on. But just looking
at this and not really analyzing it too
much, you can think that, okay, well,
just based on what it's been doing, it's
kind of been going back and forth with
some moves in between. And so when it
makes this move, well, it's probably
likely to move back up because the
market likes to just repeat what it's
doing most of the time until obviously
the trend kind of shifts. But when it's
in this kind of back and forth mode,
going into a larger time frame to see
that and understand that is really
important because then you can go into a
one minute like this or a 5m minute and
enter your trades more accurately near
the lows of that swing and you know you
could enter in right here betting that
the market was going to go up, capture
that swing and you could get something
like four times your risk in your
profits. And so that's why time frames
are really important and especially day
trading and intraday trading because
when it comes to futures intraday margin
is very very powerful and the real
reason why I think it's good to trade
futures if you're trying to swing trade
futures I think there's other better
safer assets to do that but when it
comes to day trading futures are really
really powerful because of the low
margin requirement that some brokers
have. And so that's what I use when it
comes to trading. I use a 1 minute and a
5 minute to enter and a 15 and a 30 to
analyze my charts. Now, before we jump
into drawing support and resistance
levels and candlestick patterns, I
wanted to let you know about my free
90day trader road map. It's going to
give you a step-by-step plan that you
can follow over the next 90 days to
build your trading and accelerate the
learning curve for you to become as good
of a trader as fast as possible. You can
download it for free using this QR code
or the link in the description of this
video. Now, when it comes to support and
resistance levels, they're very, very
similar to drawing these trend lines and
channels. Switching over to a 15-minute
chart here for gold. I do the same
thing. You're again using that initial
super basic foundational thing of where
are the major swings in the market and
looking at just combining those. And so
here you can see here there's a ton of
little swings right here that I would
draw a zone off of. And what I like to
do is I like to have at least two clear
swings. And then I like to draw the
bottom of the box off of the extreme
low. And then the top of the box. Again,
this is subjective. And you'll just get
better at this over time, but is taking
into account essentially where other
bottoms of the market was. And so you
can see one example here is well this
bottom happened all the way up here. But
after getting kind of this data right
here, I would only draw it basically at
this point. I wouldn't have it all the
way up here because you don't want your
zone where you're looking for the market
to bounce to be too big. I find the best
way to trade, especially off of support
or resistance zones, is waiting for the
market to hit the extremes. That's why I
actually don't look at, okay, well, you
know, there's a couple swings here. I
could draw a a resistance zone here. You
totally can. And you can draw something,
you know, off of this guy right here and
this guy right here. The key is those
are less likely to actually work out. I
find that and you know what I would
update to now is as the market's kind of
adjusting here is kind of these swings
right here because these are clear
swings in the market where it's bottom.
It's kind of a wide zone at this point.
And so with this swing we actually had
this morning, this spike here, I would
again adjust it and try and move it down
here to say, well, okay, the market's
bounced here, but those were the extreme
bounces. And when you're looking for
reversal trades, sticking to the
extremes is very, very powerful because
you're able to catch the market when
it's overextended to one direction and
you'll often get a snap back from that.
Now, it's I don't know if it's going to
happen here because if you look, we had
that already this morning. And this is
where that snapback is very powerful is
the market snapped down here with a lot
of momentum and then had a strong
reversal off of that. And it came to
this resistance or support level that
was already, I think, in place from
these two swings here. And so this is
very powerful for just a simple trading
strategy of waiting for the market to
get to extremes, having a drastic move,
and then looking for to bottom off of
that because it's overextended in an
unhealthy way. Just to show you a couple
more examples here. Here's some other
levels I've drawn. Sometimes you'll have
the market open where in this day it had
some smaller swings and I'm when I'm
intraday trading the market opened right
here. I'm thinking, okay, these are the
overnight levels that it had. I think
that it's likely to bounce between these
before it breaks out in a big way. And
so sometimes what you can do is you can
use this to see where a quick spike
higher can be. And because this is on a
15-minute chart, on a one minute chart,
what this would look like it would it
would look like more like this, a spike
higher and then a big reversal lower.
You can use that to catch essentially
the top of the market and catch a big
rip down. And so you can start to use
just these simple trend lines and swing
analysis and then support and resistance
to see what the potential is to happen
for a lot of these markets. You can say,
okay, well here there's there was this
uptrend in place. The market was going
sideways here. It broke this uptrend
this morning and then hit this
resistance level. Well, that's a pretty
good signal that the market could
reverse. And that's the whole idea of
technical analysis is just using the
basic structure of the market. Now,
where you can get in trouble is
overanalyzing. And that's why I like to
stick to where it's just super clear and
really obvious what's going on and
staying out of insanely choppy times
like this. the market the last couple
days here. You can see these are the
opening days and then this is kind of
the overnight movement. Every day here
the the NASDAQ here has pretty much just
done nothing. There's times in the
market where you'll have movements that
are just terrible for trading. Every
strategy has market conditions that are
crappy. My strategy is more of a
reversal strategy of taking trades off
of either big trend lines and looking
for a move down or off of, you know,
good support lines and looking for moves
up off of those. But any time that the
market is just sitting here chopping
like this and you can even go to a one
minute chart. Today had some good
movement for the first time. But if I
zoom in on this day, you can see it's
just back and forth. If you zoom in, it
looks like maybe there's some good
movement, but big picture again, there's
really really little movement to capture
or continuation markets are terrible
when the market is in more of a
rangebound or reversal volatile market.
And so that's why it's really important
for you to understand what markets are
good to trade in and what aren't. And
the biggest one again is choppy markets
and just learning to understand and
read, okay, well, when is there a big
movement and volatility, that's when you
want to start paying attention and
looking for potential trades. It doesn't
have to be necessarily looking for
reversals. It could be looking for
continuations if you think the trend is
really strong. Again, that's why you
look at the big picture and say, okay,
what do I think is happening? And if we
look at and analyze this, well, the
market was in a big downtrend and then
it started to have this support level.
Well, I think when it breaks this
support level, it's had all this
consolidation, which is really healthy
for the market. And so once it breaks,
it's very likely to have a large move in
that direction because it's broken this
support level. It's not overextended.
it's unlikely to fake lower and continue
higher because also looking to the left
side of the chart, there isn't great
support levels to look at. It had a kind
of a pretty strong trend up. And so big
picture, this trend could be reversing
and having a pullback before, you know,
it it does whatever it's going to do
next. And that's where if you, you know,
wondered what this would be doing next
on a bigger picture, you could zoom out
even more to, let's say, like a
60-minute chart or even a daily chart.
And that's where, you know, ignore all
the random little drawing time frames
because those are incorrect. We're on a
daily chart right now. But, you know,
looking at a daily chart, this is where
I would think, okay, we're in a clear
big uptrend. You know, we might be
having a bit of a pullback here, but I'm
assuming we're in an uptrend until we
have a clear like pullback and a double
top and, you know, something starting to
fail here. And that's where time frames
are really important to understand of
just because on a daily chart right here
the NASDAQ is in an uptrend doesn't mean
that if I go to a you know a 5minut
chart or a one minute chart I'm not
going to be looking for a short on a
shorter period time frame. You can still
be looking for shorts and longs. It just
m depends on what time frame you're
looking at and what those time frames
are telling you about the market. And so
what's really important and helpful is
understanding just basic candlestick
patterns. What these will do for you is
once you kind of understand how to read
markets, you don't really need these,
but it's a good cheat sheet when you're
first starting because if we look at
this, like here is a descending triangle
and it's basically saying, okay, the
market has a horizontal support with a
downwards trend line and the trend into
it was a downtrend. And so once it
breaks this to the downside, this
support, it's saying it's likely to
continue lower. And if we look at our
NASDAQ chart, well, you can see we
pretty much had a downwards descending
triangle right here where it had that
support level and then a downwards trend
line. And once it broke that, it had a
really big move lower. And so that's a
really good way to use these and match
them up with what's going on to help you
understand when you're starting to learn
these as a beginner. And so when it
comes to actual candlestick patterns as
well, these can really help you break
down some smaller patterns of what could
potentially be happening right at these
inflection points. Now these are all
reversal patterns. Once you kind of
understand what they mean is it really
makes a lot of sense. And so for
instance here, this one, it's a V
reversal because you have a trend coming
down quickly and then you have a hammer
candlestick pattern where the market
essentially just goes like this in that
one candlestick and then big picture it
continues higher. This candlestick
pattern essentially on a smaller time
frame, what I'm drawing here is it
essentially just makes a double top and
a double top is a larger bigger picture
structure reversal pattern. And these
ones right here is they are a momentum
switch where the market is going down in
this case really methodically and start
to slow down and you have a massive
switch in momentum. And so going through
this will really help you understand how
these can work. And another one is
essentially consolidation where the
market either here it has it in a form
of just a dogee or here it has it in the
form of multiple candlesticks where it
has a downtrend. It starts to just go
sideways and then it moves up. And so
this is also something you can get if
you get that 90-day trader road map.
It'll just be emailed to you as well.
And it's really something that is I
think really helpful for understanding
candlestick patterns. Now, I want to
jump into the personalities of these
major markets. What I trade the most is
the NASDAQ futures, the S&P 500 futures,
gold futures, and oil futures. And these
all four have different personalities
and how they react to a lot of these
patterns that we've gone over. they will
react differently to them, respect them
in a different way, which makes it
really important to actually practically
trading these because when it comes to,
you know, looking at a move like this on
gold here, I'm going to approach it
differently than a move like that on the
ES or the NASDAQ. And so, first I want
to go over the ES futures. And the major
things that I think about it is I think
one, it's great for beginners because
it's very methodical and a lot more
predictable. I think the moves in the
S&P 500 futures are a lot more solid. It
doesn't have as many fake outs in one
direction. It's not likely to spike one
way and then go the other as often. You
know, take everything with a grain of
salt. Of course, you can have, you know,
a spike like this and then a reversal,
but it's not going to be as volatile as
something like the NASDAQ. And so, the
NASDAQ, one thing about it is it's more
volatile compared to the ES. If you look
at the NASDAQ in the first 30 minutes
here, or let's just say an hour, is it
was pretty volatile. And if we look at
the ES in the first hour, just to adjust
here, it was more volatile, but it
wasn't as all over the place. The moves
were a little different. And what this
shows me is that it helps me realize,
and I think as a beginning trader, it if
you're watching ES here, instead, you
will realize that, okay, it's it's more
choppy. It's back and forth. The
market's not really sure what it wants
to do. And then when it has more of a
breakout in one direction, you can see
that okay, that is a stronger move and
you can make a decision if you think
that's an actual solid breakout or it's
a failed breakout versus the NASDAQ was
having moves all over the place very
fast. These candlesticks right here are
huge and that can be a lot harder to
trade in. Now, obviously the NASDAQ and
the ES are very correlated most of the
time. Sometimes you'll have the ES where
it's more choppy and the NASDAQ is more
movement. And so that's mainly the only
main difference between the two in terms
of direction. The NASDAQ could be doing
something like it's selling off because
it's, you know, more tech focused where
the S&P 500 futures could be actually
moving up or just kind of going
sideways. And I think if you're looking
to trade just one, which I think is the
better way to start out because trying
to look at both can be a little
confusing. I would stick to the ES
futures because they are more likely to
not fake you out and give you a better
directional movement. Now, when it comes
to respecting trend lines and levels, I
have found that the NASDAQ and the S&P
500 futures will sometimes break a trend
line after the move has already started.
So, what I mean by that is let's say we
have a trend line right here. Well, I
will sometimes see that if we're coming
down to a support level here, the entry
to jump in the trade is before the
signal of it breaking the downtrend.
Now, I don't always do this. I would say
if you're a beginner, don't do that.
Wait until it breaks a downtrend clearly
because again, that's always a very
obvious confirmation. But there's times
where the market can move really fast
and it makes sense to jump in before it
actually breaks that downtrend. But in
that case, I'm using it with idea that I
think based on what I'm seeing, it's
going to break that downtrend. Now, when
it comes to gold is I have noticed that
gold is way more methodical and respects
its trend lines more than the S&P 500
future and the NASDAQ. You know, it had
this trend line right here. And I would
not take a trade to the long side, big
picture, until it broke this downtrend.
Now, on a smaller time frame, you
totally could jump in on a long here
like this guy because the idea is, well,
if you jump in long here, let's say on
this pullback, you're going to be in the
profit before it hits where it likely
reverses here. But like for this, if you
were on a trade long right here, betting
that the market was going to go up and
you were making money as this goes up,
as soon as this breaks this trend line,
I'm going to get out of the trade
because likely with gold that it's going
to either start going sideways or go
down or, you know, maybe it'll start
continue going up, but the the trend is
over that I want to be following. Same
thing down here is it had a really
strong trend this morning uh after that
kind of move and then once it broke that
my thought was okay well it might
reverse or it might go sideways and you
know again looking at other factors I
didn't actually think that this was
going to go up cuz you can see the
bigger picture is coming into play and
pushing this thing down. Also with gold
I have found that a lot of the time
entering in on a fiveminut chart is
actually better than a one minute chart.
Now, the only time I do just because
again it's more methodical and slowm
moving now when it has some volatility
like it had this morning like this move
right here and you would know that the
volatility is happening because these
candlesticks here are showing you that
the volatility is happening and then so
when it starts to bounce here I would
jump in somewhere right here on this
pullback and bet the market was going to
go up because it's had that volatility
and I can get a trade signal based on
that. And same thing here, but you know,
for other reasons I'm not going to jump
into too much, I would think jumping in
there on a 1 minute or 5 minute would
make sense. And so kind of on that note,
going back to the ES and the NASDAQ,
though, I think you can trade both.
Again, it some of that is always going
to be personal preference. A one minute
chart is always going to be more
fast-paced, more intense, and more
likely to trigger your impulses and and
have you, you know, jump in on a trade
when maybe you shouldn't yet. Where a 5
minute is always going to have slower,
more methodical, stronger signals. But I
think you can kind of do both. What I
like to do is I like to do a 1 minute
for generally my, you know, I like to
trade and look for reversals in kind of
the first 30 minutes. And I like to use
a one minute for that because a five
minute is a little too slow for a lot of
the the whip saws and movements that
happen in that time period. Now the last
one here is oil futures and oil is a lot
trickier than these other markets I
think. Now, I probably take a trade in
oil once every few weeks or even months
because a lot of the time is it's very
kind of choppy and back and forth and
then it can have just a big move out of
nowhere. And what that's from is it's
it's because it's very newsdriven. As
you can see, if we go on a one minute
chart here, looking at this, you can see
that it's moving almost nothing. Is
because of how the candlesticks look
here. It's even gapping between each one
of these lines is a tick, which is, you
know, the smallest movement a futures
market can have. And so oil just based
on these candles, you can see that it
just looks super super choppy and it's
just not moving at all really today. And
so even on a 5minute, you can see that
okay, well, it's it's still pretty
choppy. It's having some kind of
methodical moves, but most of the time,
you know, it's just not really doing
much. Now, if I look at a one minute
chart yesterday, it did have a decent
little spike lower. Now, actually, I
think it's set up on a 5minute chart
better. And so, that's where, you know,
sometimes a 5minute is a little better.
And it doesn't mean just because on a on
a 1 minute it's choppy. It doesn't
necessarily mean it's bad to take a
trade on a 5minut. But you can see here
it had a little spike lower, came to
actually support level, and then started
to bounce. And you could have kind of
caught this initial spike and then maybe
this trend higher. But it's a lot
trickier and I very rarely take trades
in it because they don't set up very
often. But when they do, they're good
trades. That's why I like to watch it
and keep track because it can still have
really good moves. Now, if you're still
new to futures and trading and my
strategy, check out this video right
here. I'll go way more in depth on how I
actually use this technical analysis to
approach trading futures consistently
every day.